jean bessière le fait qu'on
responsabilise les français s'est jamais
une mauvaise chose puisqu'on les
infantiliser depuis un an maintenant et
ça mais bon là il ya pas mal de gens je
vous le dis je et vous savez que tu pas
voilà je suis assez impartiale et voilà
je le dis hein il ya beaucoup de gens
qui l'ont trouvé bon ce soir je vous le
dis d'abord il a annoncé très peu de
choses finalement quand on quand on
réfléchit par rapport à la situation des
interdits est à partir de 5 avril
c'était pas la folle il a parlé d'une
taille c'est à dire la vaccination est
l' augmentation capacitaire de
réanimation alors il nous dit emmanuel
macron qui voit la lumière au bout du
tunnel moi je vois pas comment il fait
pour l'avoir à moins qu'il ait des des
lunettes de vision nocturne je vois pas
où ils voient la lumière dans la
situation actuelle
d'autant plus que effectivement à la
fois en termes de vaccins et en termes
de lits de réanimation pour l'instant le
gouvernant a raconté que des cracks de
minutes jouées jusqu'à 10 g pied gauche
maintenant il faudrait qu'ils aillent
chercher des boulettes chez ma mère sans
rigoler c'est pas une vanne mais
personne n'est venu chercher ton repas
voilà donc je le dis voilà donc je
disais que pour l'instant mari emmanuel
macron et olivier véran ne sont pas aux
commandes en matière d'approvisionnement
des vaccins puisque c'est l'union
européenne qui livre dont qui sont
tributaires de ça donc toutes les
promesses qu'ils nous font en fait nous
engagent que ceux qui les entendent
c'est à dire honnêtement vous n'y croyez
pas cette histoire à écouter - quand on
m'a annoncé 12 mille lits en août 2020
au cas où ça où les choses tournent au
vinaigre et qu'elles sont en train de
tourner au vinaigre et qu'on n'a pas vu
le début du commencement du moindre lits
supplémentaires
permettez-moi ne pas croire en ça je
dire le mans le gouvernement n'a fait
que mentir surtout depuis le début il
s'est décrédibilisé en même temps que la
décrédibiliser la parole publique
donc moi si vous voulez moi j'aimerais
bien croire à sa meilleure d'ailleurs
hâte moi moi moi je vais vous dire moi
ce que j'ai aimé je dis ouais c'est
qu'on a un calendrier après et nous et
nous moi et l'ensemble des français qui
nous regardent ils ont envie de le
croire mais c'est mieux c'est ce qu'a
dit stéphane de piste des calendriers
ont reçu à boire on va s'élancer on va
après les limes à méditer
alors là landrier il avait quand même
annoncé initialement qu'au 15 avril on
commencerait à réunir progressivement on
s'aperçoit qu'aucun avoir aussi je vous
êtes en train de réfléchir à aarau
confiné donc moi si vous voulez je
jouais tout en haut
il a d'ailleurs lui même si on la
perçoit pas ce qu'il dit à un moment il
faut revenir à une stratégie nationale
il faut produire les vaccins
nationalement lui même reconnaît entre
les lignes
effectivement que la stratégie euro 6
qui l'a évacué européiste vaccinale
qu'on a adopté depuis un an est un échec
cuisant il le reconnaît lui même